bonjour à tous place dans un instant à
l'audition d'hervé collignon hervé
collignon et vice-président du cabinet
at kearney il est spécialisé dans les
télécommunications dans les médias dans
les nouvelles technologies a également
été professeur à l'université
californienne de stanford
il a donc été auditionnée par la mission
commune d'information sur la gouvernance
mondiale d'internet une mission qui
s'intéresse plus particulièrement au
rôle et à la place de l'europe dans
cette gouvernance mondiale
il faut dire que la matière l'europe est
plutôt à la traîne par rapport aux
géants américains
même si l'europe a décidé la création
d'un marché unique du numérique à
l'horizon 2020 et bien il y a urgence à
agir c'est ce qu'a dit la rapporteur de
cette mission commune d'information
catherine morin desailly il faut agir
pour que l'europe ne devienne pas simple
consommateur d'un monde qui est en train
de se faire sans elle
tout de suite dont un retour à cette
audition qui s'est déroulé mi mars salle
clémenceau nous a semblé avec catherine
morin desailly qui est avec moi qu'il
pouvait tout à fait utile de replacer
cette question de l'internet dans cette
perspective plus globale des enjeux pour
l'europe de sa présence dans les
secteurs de nouvelles technologies et
donc on souhaitait vraiment vous
entendre que nous propose lettre de vous
laisser la parole pour nous présenter le
contexte et les principales conclusions
auxquelles vous êtes parvenu que la
prend pour échanger avec le 4e bras j'ai
pu directement
sachant que
tout ça est retranscrit ensuite donc
lorsque votre ce que vous nous dites
ensuite et publiée dans cadre jeu sur le
site du sénat dans le cadre de la
mission qui est la nôtre parfait mais
écoutez je vous remercie en tout cas
infiniment d'avoir sollicité pour
contribuer à cette réflexion importante
évidemment mon intervention sera
davantage un éclairage point de vue de
contexte sur la problématique beaucoup
plus large que vous que vous traitez
nous avons effectivement publié cette
étude sur l'industrie high-tech
européenne mais nous avons également
comme je vous le disais publié
précédemment
d'autres études sur la souhaitable
adaptation du modèle de réglementation
de l'internet dont je pourrais peut-être
à la fin on exposait vous rappeler les
principales conclusions
alors donc je suis le co auteur donc de
cette de cette étude l'ad'ailleurs étude
européenne écrite avec deux collègues
allemands et suédois
donc sur la place des entreprises
européennes dans l'industrie des
technologies de l'information
or l'étude elle repose sur des analyses
quantitatives et documentaires comme
nous avons l'habitude de faire mais
également avec les échanges que nous
avons avec les dirigeants des
entreprises de ce secteur ainsi que pour
le cas d'espèce des représentants de
l'union européenne qu'ils sont keith qui
s'occupe de ces questions alors tout je
voulais juste simplement commencé en
rappelant simplement pourquoi le secteur
de la technologie est un secteur
important sinon une industrie qui à
l'échelle européenne
correspond encore à trois millions
d'emplois aujourd'hui elle répond à une
demande qui est une demande en forte
croissante croissance ces 700 millions
pendant 700 milliards de dollars pour le
marché européen
donc en croissance et dans un contexte
de crise économique
s'attacher aux secteurs qui sont en
croissance évidemment est un est un
élément important c'est également bien
sûr une source de revenus fils cours
pour pour les états mais alors au delà
même de son attractivité direct la
technologie comme vous le savez
transforme un grand nombre de secteurs
et notamment des secteurs industriels
dans lequel l'europe est forte
aujourd'hui je prends qu'un exemple qui
est l'automobile la technologie
électronique embarquée d'une d'une
voiture va représenter d'après nos
prévisions en 2015 jusqu'à 65 % de la
valeur d'un véhicule
donc c'est un cetain c'est une
illustration la technologie impact si
des questions de société qui deviennent
du coup des questions stratégiques pour
l'europe autour de la santé autour de
l'énergie autour de la sécurité des
informations
et donc on regard des récentes
révélations qui j'imagine sont un petit
peu l'origine également de la réflexion
actuelle donc l'existence de programmes
de surveillance des échanges
électroniques
les entreprises et les gouvernements
européens seront sans doute réticents à
dépendre exclusivement de fournisseurs
qui sont américains ou qui sont
asiatiques alors je vais pas rentrer
dans le détail de l'étude spécifiquement
simplement rappelé que ce que nous
appelons là
le secteur high tech il faut bien
prendre une définition donc nous l'avons
décrit comme étant une somme de neuf
segments qui vont des semi conducteurs
en passant par les composants
électroniques jusqu'aux systèmes
électroniques les systèmes de
télécommunication ceux qui servent à
créer les réseaux tout ce qu'on appelle
le consumer electronics donc la partie
journée grand public ainsi que les
sociétés de services informatiques qui
sont très actives également dans ce
secteur là au total ce secteur selon
cette définition
donkey et or télécom hors internet je
parlerai un tout petit peu de cet aspect
après à lui seul déjà représente 2700
milliards de dollars dans le monde et au
sein de ses 2700 milliards
l'europe représente 700 donc milliards
soit une le quart à peu près de la
demande mondiale du secteur alors
évidemment l'étude met en évidence que
la place des acteurs européens dans cet
univers est faible et par ailleurs
qu'elle est en recul
lorsque nous avons listé les dix
premières entreprises de chacun de ces
sous segments on ne trouve donc c'est un
peu le top 100 nouvelles la technologie
mondiale
on ne trouve que huit acteurs européens
dans ce palmarès
si l'on considère notamment que nokia
qui est encore le troisième fabricant de
terminaux dans le monde va passer sous
bannière américaine
donc l'europe est absente de secteurs
entiers en tout cas du top 10 de
certains secteurs
les composants électroniques donc hors
semi-conducteurs toute l'électronique
grand public et séville entre occupants
la veille de la vague des objets
connectés
absent des ordinateurs portables des
smartphones des tablettes tous ses
segments qui sont aujourd'hui très
largement dominé par les asiatiques et
les américains alors il ya quelques
belles positions qu'il faut souligner
donc pour l'europe notamment dans le
segment des équipements
télécommunications ericsson nokia
siemens alcatel lucent qui sont
respectivement 2e à 4e et 5e mondiaux du
secteur
les sociétés de services informatiques
capgemini atos t systems il tourne
autour de la 8e à la 12e place dans le
secteur du logiciel il ya un acteur qui
est zappé un sol qui est 4e mondial et
puis dans le semi conducteurs dont un
champion qui stmicroelectronics qui est
7e mondial donc on voit que l'europe
dispose encore de quelques champions
dont notamment dans les activités plutôt
professionnelle vers que l'europe et
semble presque définitivement exclu du
segment grand public ce qui pose des
questions sur la capacité de l'europe à
créer des marques fortes
en tout cas il y a des champions
aujourd'hui qui sont assez gros pour
être des acteurs de la consolidation au
moins dans leur spécialité
alors quelles sont les pistes qui
s'offrent aujourd'hui pour corriger
cette situation
cela passe par une analyse succincte des
raisons pour lesquelles on en est arrivé
à cette situation
alors il ya des raisons qui sont
structurels des raisons qui sont liés
peut-être là la culture et la richesse
européenne mais il y en a aussi beaucoup
qui tiennent à la politique industrielle
ou plutôt à son absence depuis au moins
une quinzaine d'années est par ailleurs
des orientations réglementaire et la
façon dont l'europe et les états ont
priorisé secteur eon flécher les
investissements qu'elle souhaitait
alloués à ce secteur
donc j'allais rapidement sur les causes
du retard tels qu'ils ont été identifiés
à travers cette cette analyse
tout d'abord l'importance du marché
domestique ça reste l'argument
économique principal en fait pour toutes
questions européennes
donc ce marché domestique qui si on
considère que c'est un marché
l'europe c'est un marché qui est
important massif
un peu plus faible que le marché
américain tout de même et surtout en
croissance plus faible que le marché
américain alors que l'asie pour pour
pour ce qui est de la technologie donc
deux et demi pour cent de croissance
prévus dans les trois ans contre à peu
près 5 à 6 % dans les autres régions
donc c'est un déséquilibré c'est un
déséquilibre qui est bien sûr aggravée
par julie rey la faiblesse relative des
mesures de préférence domestique
quand on compare la façon dont les
donneurs d'ordre européens se comporte
vis à vis de leurs fournisseurs par
rapport à la façon dont les asiatiques
se comporte vis à vis de leurs
fournisseurs et la même chose pour les
pour les américains donc mécaniquement
la relative faiblesse de la demande
européenne comparé aux autres régions a
tendance à défavoriser les acteurs
européens alors une deuxième point c'est
que quand bien même on parlerait d'un
marché domestique et d'un marché
domestique vaste et attractif savoir que
bien entendu le mas le marché européen
est bien plus complexe à servir que le
marché américain par exemple
donc ça se traduit concrètement par une
difficulté pour les entreprises à
atteindre les effets d'échelle dont
elles ont besoin par la suite pour
pouvoir exporter pour pouvoir être forte
et conquérante
à l'international en fait en europe pour
réussir en europe
il faut réussir cinq fois de suite il
faut réussir sur les cinq premiers
marchés européens avant de pouvoir
prétendre bénéficier des effets
d'échelle ce qui n'est évidemment pas le
cas aux états unis où finalement la
stratégie dans en californie et dans le
dakota est assez similaire
en tout cas il ya pleinement beaucoup
plus d'homogénéité dans les différents
états américains
troisième point ça a été je crois a
évoqué très souvent faiblesse du
financement
qu'il s'agisse de fonds privés
capital-risque de fonds publics d'accès
au crédit
tout ceci est beaucoup plus faible en
europe par rapport par rapport notamment
aux états unis
je crois qu'il ya quatre milliards de
financements par le capital-risque en
2012 pour l'europe contre 20 milliards
aux états unis donc c'est assez
emblématique de penser que spotify par
exemple qui est une start-up
effectivement bien connu et qui pourrait
être un fleuron européen a dû faire
appel à du capital risque américain pour
assurer son développement international
alors c'est vrai aussi pour les fonds
publics parce que ces fonds publics sont
souvent fléché quand même dans un sens
en tout cas tourné de façon après
préférentiel vers des fournisseurs
locaux le gouvernement américain c'est
une source gartner dépensant 80
milliards en haïti et ses 50% de plus
que l'ensemble des états européens réuni
120 milliards à peu près et tout ceci et
ça c'est sans compter les
investissements liés au département de
la défense
et quand vous savez bien sûr encore bien
plus important en tout cas relativement
parlant par rapport par rapport à
l'europe alors moins de financement de
la r&d également moins de productivité
de la r&d l'europe consacre au global
1.5.2 pnb de moins que ce que fait le
japon ou et un pour cent de moins que ce
que fait les états unis ce que font les
états unis
or l'impact de la r&d ça se mesure en
tout cas son son potentiel c'est
vraiment liée à la masse c'est pas une
question de pourcentage caisson de masse
donc c'est pour ça que l'on s'est
attaché vraiment regarder qui était gros
parce qu'être être gros c'est ça qui est
important quand il s'agit de r&d ont
juste un exemple quand samsung investi 5
% de son chiffre d'affaires en r&d ce
qui dans l'absolu ne semble pas une
pourcentage extrêmement élevé mais ça
veut dire qu'ils mettent sur la table
11 milliards d'euros tous les ans pour
progresser sur des marchés comme les
smartphones et les objets connectés par
ailleurs quand on regarde le nombre de
brevets déposés en europe c'est pas un
hasard de trouver que samsung est
l'entreprise qui dépose le plus de
brevets en europe très largement devant
et le double du premier européen qui est
ericsson alors il ya une autre faiblesse
évidemment qui est mise en avant par
l'étude et ça fait écho à d'autres
débats en europe et notamment en france
c'est la faible production de nombre
d'ingénieurs diplômés en sciences dures
mathématiques physique technologie
informatique faut savoir qu'en europe
c'est seulement 17 % des étudiants
européens qui choisit ses filières alors
qu'à taïwan en chine et au japon ses 30%
il ya 700 mille ingénieurs informatiques
qui sont publiques qui sont diplômés en
chine tous les ans contre 500 milles sur
l'ensemble de l'europe
aujourd'hui je passerai rapidement sur
bien sûr les coûts de production la
flexibilité du marché de l'emploi qui
évidemment sont pas favorables à la
prise de risque en europe notamment pour
les pme
on rappelle qu'il ya toujours une
différence majeure une heure de
fabrication normes de l'ouest coûte 15
fois plus qu'une heure de fabrication en
chine et en europe de l'est
et encore quatre fois plus cher qu'en
chine enfin il ya trois autres causes
qui sont intéressantes parce qu'elle
tout ça ce sont des causes
d'environnement qui aurait
il y en a également trois autres qui
sont identifiés par par l'ensemble des
acteurs qui qui qui ont trait à la
politique industrielle et aux pratiques
de management est également de ces
entreprises
premier élément c'est que après avoir
montré la voie dans les années 80 avec
le gsm la mise en place de partenariats
stratégiques entre des fournisseurs et
des clients publics
donc c'était à l'époque ericsson avec ce
qui s'appelle maintenant teliasonera
donc l'opérateur local
c'était alcatel avec france télécom ce
type de collaboration a pratiquement
disparu depuis 20 ans dans ce secteur
alors qu'aux états unis vous savez par
pertinemment le rôle de la darpa donc
élément fondateur de l'existence même
d'internet
l'europe semble avoir refusé de soutenir
la consolidation de champion high tech
comme elle a su le faire autour d'airbus
par exemple de l'automobile
un deuxième élément qui était bien sûr
un élément dans également un peu
d'environnement et culture qui est
certaine frilosité vis-à-vis de
l'entrepreneuriat en europe
c'est pas vrai dans toutes les régions
d'europe mais il ya eu des débats lors
je ne sais pas je j'aime la réflexion de
de jacques attali là-dessus disant qu'on
a
la france a choisi la terre plutôt que
la mer je sais pas si c'est vrai je sais
c'est intéressant enfin il est certain
que les politiques fiscales et
administratives en général ne sont pas
aussi activement incitatives qu'elle
pourrait être pour réduire les risques
inhérents à la création d'entreprise
perd malheureusement à sécuriser assez
important aussi été relevées alors le
dernier élément qui est quand même
important aussi c'est toute l'industrie
fait un petit peu également seront son
diagnostic critique envers elle même
c'est un élément important donc
reconnaissance que certains virages ont
été mal négociées
l'exemple c'est le tactile l'importance
du logiciel embarqué dans l'est dans les
terminaux qui sont probablement deux
ruptures qui ont été fatales à nokia
notamment
alors ce sujet là évidemment c'est un
sujet qui est inhérent au secteur dont
on parle c'est ce que la cie en
management appelle le dilemme de
l'innovateur qui consiste quand il est
quand il est leader de décider à un
moment donné qu'il doit scier la branche
sur laquelle il est assis
à défaut de quoi ce sera un concurrent
qui va le faire à sa place
maintenant ce sujet là n'a rien de
spécifique à l'europe
les américains et les asiatiques sont
confrontés à la même au même dilemme
dans permanence alors nous ce qu'on a ce
qu'on a noté toutefois dans le mode de
management
c'est que il y a une part peut-être plus
importante qui ait donné la vision
stratégique en asie avec des plans à
long terme qui sont une pratique
courante grande stabilité également dans
les dents les directions générales et
par ailleurs le modèle américain qui est
plutôt une vision un carnet du leader du
gourou paranoïaque est en tout cas ces
deux modèles qui sont extrêmement
différents à leur façon ont tendance à
privilégier peut-être le long terme
sur le court terme et donc en tout cas
permettent problement à ces entreprises
de mieux anticiper
le leadership classique des sociétés
européennes de technologie
ça reste souvent un modèle avec un
conseil d'administration qui nomme un
pdg pour un mandat relativement court
terme ce n'est pas forcément un mandat
de gestion facile ça peut être un mandat
de gestion de crise mais en tous cas
rarement avec peut-être la sérénité et
la confiance dont ils auraient besoin
pour concilier cette vision long terme
et court terme qu'il faut toujours avoir
dans ce type de secteur
il ya quelques exemples qui illustrent
ça plutôt positivement autour de nous
qui montre que certaines entreprises
deviennent des leaders
il ya des exemples en france jeunes
dassault systèmes en est un avec
effectivement cette incarnation je
dirais d'un dirigeant visionnaire où il
ya eu des avancées alcatel qui a eu
quand même une une stabilité importante
à sa tête pendant gérer les années plus
tôt de conquête d'alcatel donc la
faiblesse des entreprises européennes
s'explique par des nature extrêmement
diverses la question et que peut-on
faire
soulignons simplement que l'europe n'est
pas immobile notre étude montre bien en
tout cas souligne les avancées l'union
européenne notamment à travers son plan
horizon 2020 qui est doté d'un budget de
80 milliards d'euros un budget qui est
en croissance de 25% par rapport au plan
précédent
alors comme comme les plans précédents
ce plan vise essentiellement à renforcer
l'excellence scientifique plutôt tourné
vers les secteurs en rupture qui sont
bien identifiés et qui sont les secteurs
à fort enjeu pour l'europe et avec la
nouveauté cette fois ci d'avoir un volet
industriel clairement explicité qui vise
à favoriser certaines technologies clés
donc l'initiative européenne va dans le
bon sens il allait probablement
insuffisante au regard des enjeux
auxquels l'industrie fait face alors
leur nez quoi on est à 0 7 point de pipe
à la répartie sur rassemble 2 2 sur 8
ont tout à fait répartis sur huit ans
est relativement dispersé je pense que
c'est un des points qui est extrêmement
important et donc ça fait partie je
dirais des recommandations un petit peu
ce groupe d'études s'attend de piste 10
pistes
ils sont peut-être classés par par
grands thèmes il ya d'abord quatre
pistes qui sont d'agir sur ce qu'on peut
les catalyseurs les facilitateurs lésiné
blur en anglais
d'abord sur l'offre d'ingénieurs et de
personnels qualifiés davantage de
programmes scientifiques davantage de
mise en valeur dans les systèmes
éducatifs traditionnel formelle mais
aussi faire appel
plus largement aux cours à distance et
puis alors à plus court terme vraiment
regarder dans le sens de l'immigration
choisie
faire venir des talents c'est crucial
pour gérer la pénurie à court terme
tout ceci dans une stratégie près de
cluster pour créer l'infrastructure
éducative d'accueil et une large place
donnée à l'anglais alors faute ou pas
c'est en anglais mais en tout cas il est
évident que les conditions d'accueil des
étudiants étrangers doit être favorisé
le deuxième point c'est le financement
de la technologique évidemment donc là
il ya plein de choses possibles
comme vous le savez le capital-risque
vous capital investissement peut-être
favorisé fiscalement les fonds publics
spécifiques qui peuvent être développées
les outils financiers tacle crédit à
l'export les prêts développement les
assurances contre le défaut de paiement
peuvent être développées je pense le
système bancaire européen peut jouer un
rôle extrêmement important pour soutenir
pour soutenir cette industrie
l'europe ne dispose pas évidemment les
clients du nasdaq américain qui bien
entendu est clé pour accéder aux
financements et pour rassurer les
capitaux risqueurs donc évident une
chaîne de chose qui peut être mise en
place fait référence au 11e plan
quinquennal chinois qui illustrent que
c'est possible
ce plan a de nos entreprises et par
différents les plus grosses un support
gouvernemental pour
l'internationalisation ces sociétés sous
forme de financement d'assurance de
dédouanement de dérogation vis-à-vis de
la flexibilité de l'emploi troisième
catalyseur le support l'entrepreneuriat
je vais assez vite là dessus vous
connaissez bien entendu les les leviers
s'est gardé des leviers culturelles tout
a commencé à célébrer les succès
entrepreneuriaux n'est pas forcément
forcément dans notre habitude mais c'est
aussi bien sûr développer les filières
entrepreneuriale dans les cursus
d'ingénieurs notamment flexibiliser
l'emploi pour les startups permettent
pour leur remettre d'embauché plutôt
d'être en avance de phase et non pas en
réaction parce qu'on attend d'elle
qu'elle prenne des risques les grands
entreprises également sont concernés
favoriser les incubateurs
il ya de très bons exemples et saper a
mis en place un incubateur en
partenariat avec le hasso plattner
institute qui avaient leur a permis de
développer le système stockage
anna qui qui pourrait s'imposer comme
une plateforme européenne pour le big
data
enfin il ya 1 3 il ya un quatrième
catalyseur qui je crois est très
important c'est de créer
ce qu'on appelle des conditions de
concurrence équitables pour les
entreprises européennes avec une
perspective mondiale
donc ces données l'appréciation de la
concurrence la perspective au bon niveau
on l'a vu l'europe
structurellement nous permet pas aux
entreprises bénéficier des effets
d'échelle dont peuvent bénéficier les
entreprises chinoises ou américaines
encore faut dire que l'europe ce assure
que la priorité qui est donné
aujourd'hui au bénéfice consommateur ne
se traduisent pas par une réglementation
qui dégraderait la compétitivité des
entreprises
évidemment l'exemple c'est le secteur
des télécommunications qui m'est chère
qui a vu ses profits fortement raboté en
europe appels internationaux au roaming
introduction nouveaux entrants l'effet à
court terme de c2c de ces mesures a été
concrètement de contraindre les
investissements alors même que comme
vous savez les trafics explosé qu'il
faut investir dans les réseaux de
favoriser l'offshore et de favoriser
également des fournisseurs non européens
qui sont capables d'offrir des distante
parce qu'ils sont en conquête de marchés
les lois anti concentration
elle vise à assurer la pluralité mais
elles peuvent aussi des favoriser
l'émergence d' effets d'échelle et de
champion qui soit capable de rivaliser
que les concurrents mondiaux
donc on voit l'europe et les états à
travers la législation les associations
à travers des mesures comme les
certifications peuvent favoriser
l'industrie européenne certaines
d'autres nations n'hésite pas à le faire
et n'hésite pas à utiliser ces tactiques
donc éducation financement en
entrepreneuriat appréciation globale de
la concurrence ce sont quatre thèmes qui
sont des thèmes qui devaient être
partagés par l'ensemble des des états en
europe pour être compétitif c'est plutôt
plus d'europe sur tout et surtout pas
moins et c'est un mandat clair de
croissance pour pour cette industrie
le deuxième élément important c'est
d'être focalisé et la proposition qui
est faite ici c'est que la focalisation
soit organisé ou facilité par les grands
donneurs d'ordre on a vu il ya des
ressources fait vu mobilisés en europe
il faut sans doute les accroître mais
surtout ne pas éparpiller ses ressources
donc pour ça il faudrait un plan
d'ensemble à l'échelle européenne qui
définirait en concertation avec les
industriels les associations les
domaines investissements technologiques
qui sont prioritaires
donc on ce pour ça il faut tenir compte
évidemment des caractéristiques de la
demande des citoyens européens autour
des systèmes de santé autour des
systèmes de protection sociale
autour d'eux des transports de
l'éducation également en fonction des
secteurs économiques dans lesquels
l'europe est déjà forte
aujourd'hui je lui dis l'automobile les
industries de process les
télécommunications les institutions
financières et des utilities est donc
orienté plutôt les investissements de
technologie vers la transformation à
venir de ces secteurs
deuxième élément de focalisation c'est
de créer des clusters d'excellence on
rajoute à ça la notion de la soeur
d'excellence paneuropéen donc il ya
peut-être encore un cran plus loin par
rapport à ce qui est fait dans beaucoup
dans beaucoup d'états savoir que donc
l'efficacité des clusters évidemment
aujourd'hui n'est plus à démontrer tout
le monde est assez d'accord avec
avec avec ce concept cela 10 pour les
créer savoir où les créé il ya des
arbitrages qui devait être fait et notre
notre idée c'est qu'il faut davantage
les orienter là où sont les grands
donneurs d'ordre des secteurs que l'on
souhaite favoriser plutôt que pour
aménager tel ou tel territoire
si on peut faire les deux c'est mieux
mais on pourrait imaginer de confier le
leadership par exemple de la
transformation de l'industrie automobile
plutôt à l'allemagne les télécoms à
stockholm la défense la sécurité
l'aéronautique en france c'est partager
l'évolution de la banque à londres
on n'est pas du tout loin aujourd'hui
des jarres de cette situation l'idée
serait d'aller peut-être encore plus
loin autour de la santé de ligue
gouvernement de lee éducation éducation
donc choisir les pays qui sont les plus
en avance sur ces différents sujets et
non pas leur donner l'exclusivité de la
du progrès et du développement mais en
tout cas alors ne leur donnez le pronom
le leadership
bon évidemment après flécher les
investissements selon le master plan
défini et les clusters dons
dont on a parlé plus tôt voilà alors
tout ça ça ça contribue à améliorer
l'environnement extérieur pour les
entreprises du secteur étant donné le
point de départ enfin tout cas le point
où on en est aujourd'hui
tout ceci est probablement indispensable
d'être mené de front dire qu'en fait
l'écart est quand même et quand même
extrêmement important quand on quand on
regarde les chiffres mais il ya
également un certain nombre de choses
bien sûr que nous appelons l'excellence
dans la gestion des entreprises de
technologies autour des pratiques autour
du leadership et je vais m'attarder trop
là dessus mais il ya évidemment des
choses à faire évoluer également dans la
façon dont dont on gère et dont on
formule la stratégie dont on privilégie
l'innovation et la rai la r&d aux dépens
de la rentabilité peut être à court
terme et remettre à jour les
partenariats clients fournisseurs comme
étant des véhicules d'innovation comme
ça a été fait par le passé et comme
c'est fait dans beaucoup d'autres
industries
voilà donc pour cette étude la
conclusion c'est qu'on pourra pas
répliquer exactement toutes les comptes
toutes les conditions qui ont permis aux
entreprises technologiques de se
développer aux états unis ou en asie
la structure fédérale 2
de l'europe est une source de richesse
mais également une faiblesse qui
résultent souvent des opérations qui
sont sous critique fragmenté et des
retours d'un livre sur investissement
qui sont souvent plus faibles mais comme
croire on l'a évoqué il y a quand même
beaucoup de pistes à exploiter à tous
les niveaux pour faire repartir
l'europe de la technologie je vais vous
dire un petit mot sur l'aspect télécoms
et internet qui peut être un peu plus
encore dans le coeur de votre réflexion
si on a beaucoup parlé donc de tous tous
ces secteurs industriels baky qui
contribue à faire que les réseaux et que
l'internet fonctionne donc on a parlé
ces situations là les réseaux qui sont
ce sur quoi bien sûr les pure players
internet dont vous parlez beaucoup bien
sûr dans cette commission
ce sur quoi c'est players appui pour
développer leurs services
alors pour parler d'industrie mondial
des télécoms c'est 1400 milliards de
dollars 12 un peu plus petit que
l'industrie high tech dont on a parlé
avant il a si on faisait le top 10
mondial dans cette industrie
on retrouverait cette fois quatre
acteurs européens dans le top 10
c'est à dire telefonica deutsche telekom
vodafone orange orange étant la limite
9e 10e
mais voilà on trouverait quatre acteurs
européens dans dans ce segment là donc
les opérateurs de télécommunications
constituent incontestablement la force
de l'europe sur l'ensemble de ce secteur
à l'échelle mondiale et
il est important de bien sûr de savoir
ces acteurs sont fragilisés aujourd'hui
leur profitabilité et sous pression
alors il ya beaucoup de choses qu'il
doit faire eux mêmes ils doivent
s'adapter doivent changer et nouveau il
évolue dans un coin dans un cadre
réglementaire qui probablement doit être
remise en question en tout cas qui doit
évoluer parce que la situation des
télécoms n'est pas celle des années 90
le monde a beaucoup changé et c'est en
tout cas l'intérêt bien compris de
l'europe tout entière et de toute la
filière technologique dont on a parlé
avant on a fait des travaux nous sur la
chaîne de valeurs internet
on a quantifié les choses et ces travaux
montrent que quand on regarde l'ensemble
de la chaîne de valeurs de l'internet le
le segment de la communication donc les
opérateurs correspond au segment pour
lequel les retours sur capitaux engagés
sont les plus faibles de toute la chaîne
est notamment très significativement
inférieurs à ceux des pure players
internet qui se trouve au dessus des
réseaux ils sont pris en ciseaux
pour leur profitabilité avec d'un côté
des prix qui baissent et par ailleurs la
nécessité de maintenir un niveau
d'investissement voire de l'accroître
pour assurer les capacités de transport
des informations
or le secteur des télécoms est comme
vous savez réglementée et
particulièrement réglementés en europe
je dirais une attention toute
particulière donnée par parler les
réglementent heures en europe par
rapport par exemple que la f6 ci peut
faire alors même que celui de l'internet
ne l'est quasiment pas or ces deux
mondes s'interpénètrent aujourd'hui
l'actualité il ya quelques semaines
c'est facebook qui rachète whatsapp 19
milliards de dollars
ça nous dit deux choses ça nous dit
d'une part qu'il y a une puissance
financière extrêmement importante
aujourd'hui ces acteurs ont une réalité
économiques derrière derrière leur
existence et ça nous dit aussi qu'il
rentre de face en ce moment frontale
dans le marché ou dans le secteur des
communications interpersonnelles
j'ai regardé également la publication
récente des résultats du groupe donc
orange france télécom qui vient de
sortir et je le compare à celui de
google va sortir pour 2013 je trouve que
c'est ça donne une illustration du
propos qui est assez intéressante
également donc le chiffre d'affaires
d'orange ressort à 41 milliards d'euros
pour l'ensemble du groupe en baisse de 4
et demi pour cent avec ce long
communiqué la moitié de cet effet qui
est qualifé des faits réglementaire
alors même que google va publier un
chiffre d'affaires de l'ordre de 60
milliards de dollars à comparer aux 40
d'euros en hausse de 19%
le modèle économique de google quand on
regarde un petit peu les comptes lui
permet par ailleurs d'allouer 8
milliards de dollars
la r&d quand je pense que le groupe
orange
il consacre beaucoup moins d'un milliard
aujourd'hui donc à titre de comparaison
vous évoquiez dans une audition
précédente la possibilité de favoriser
des moteurs de recherche alternatifs etc
faut savoir que voilà avec 8 milliards
de dollars tous les ans dépenser en r&d
pour embaucher les meilleurs ingénieurs
en algorithmique
il va falloir aider très très
significativement l'émergence d'une
alternative que tout le monde appelle de
ses voeux mais pour ça maintenant on est
plus passer dans un mode start up on est
vraiment dans l'économie réelle alors à
la fin du compte malgré tout ça google
présente un cash flow opérationnel de 18
milliards de dollars
vous êtes ce qui lui reste pour pouvoir
investir en hausse de 10% alors que
l'ebitda qui à peu près l'équivalent un
agrégat équivalent du côté du groupe
orange
il est de 13 milliards d'euros en baisse
contenue
d'ailleurs je vous le rendre c'est un
bon résultat en baisse seulement 2 5% et
7 ce cash flow opérationnel il est
utilisé aujourd'hui google investit en
7 milliards de dollars dans
l'infrastructure
ce sont bien sûr des serveurs des data
center mais c'est aussi des réseaux et
c'est beaucoup plus que le groupe orange
enfin c'est plus que groupe orange on
sait au moins autant c'est 5,6 milliards
pour le groupe orange
donc on voit que ces deux secteurs sont
évidemment interpénétrés que par
ailleurs la seule façon pour les
opérateurs de télécoms de retrouver la
croissance c'est d'aller vers des
modèles qui sont des modèles au tt qui
sont des modèles adjacent or un secteur
est régulée et fortement je dirais donc
pas contrôler mais en tout cas sous
vigilance permanente alors que l'autre
ne l'est absolument pas voilà donc au
tour des sujets comme les subventions
croisées qui évidemment la base même du
modèle de modèle de google crée des
package les prix de gros les prix de
détail la capacité à se consolider
imaginons un monde où le groupe orange
fera bon se rapproche du groupe français
l'équipe du groupe deutsch telekom on ne
créerait guère plus qu'un opérateur qui
pèserait 100 milliards de dollars
ce serait nous sans que c'est une étape
importante qui paraît ambitieuse en
réalité ça ne ferait finalement qu'un
acteur de 100 milliards de dollars de
chiffre d'affaires avec donc les
capacités d'investissements et de r&d
qui
qui vont avec voilà donc les conclusions
un petit peu de cette partie là de des
différentes études qu'on a pu mener l
appelait le cadre réglementaire européen
a évolué selon un salon de direction
autour de trois axes essentiellement
s'il ya plus de liberté dans les prix la
ilaha illa il allie la capacité à price
et plus de liberté notamment dans
l'innovation dans les services adjacente
à dire les sortir du cadre
enfin en tout cas créer un environnement
de concurrence loyale sur ces secteurs
est bien entendu plus de liberté pour se
consolider
puisqu'il est évident que les effets
d'échelle reste je dirais larmes
principal pour pouvoir réussir dans un
secteur avec des coûts fixes extrêmement
extrêmement élevé voila voila un petit
peu les éléments je voulais partager
avec vous si beaucoup énormément de
choses dans ce que vous avez dit je
laissais à catherine morin desailly le
choix de prolonger un peu la discussion
oui je vous remercie de cette excellente
exposé qui est extrêmement clair et
précis je vois votre étude est publiée
depuis en 2014 sur cette année ça voilà
parce qu'ils ont elles été publié un
mois fin les échos ont parlé ski
il me satisfait c'est que ça correspond
au diagnostic que nous avions posé il ya
plus d'un an avec la commission des
affaires européennes de contrôle de mes
collègues jaloux et andré gattolin quand
j'avais proposé mon rapport sur l'union
européenne et le numérique
je note que ont été co auteur de cette
étude
un allemand l'insolence les doigts ce
qui nous intéresse c'est de savoir
justement quel est le degré de prise de
conscience dans les autres états membres
de ce qui est en train de se passer pour
pouvoir avancer justement sur
l'évolution du cadre réglementaire une
liberté à donner aux acteurs pour
construire une véritable stratégie parce
que parfois on se sent un peu isolé
alors évidemment on se sent plus être
trop au centre du monde
ça c'est peut-être aussi une
méconnaissance de ce qui se passe
ailleurs mais c'est important si de
trouver des partenariats pour pouvoir
avancer sur sur ce sujet bien un thème
que vous n'avez pas évoquer ou tout
simplement effleuré au tout début quand
vous avez parlé de leurs entrées
fiscales
c'est la question de la fiscalité et du
phénomène
d'optimisations fiscales qui existent à
l'heure actuelle est ce que vous avez
réfléchit aussi à des pistes de votre de
votre côté et puis une question
peut-être pour eux elle est un peu plus
loin dans le dernier propos vous avez
tenu comment on peut résister vous
développer des stratégies pour des
contres phénomène d'aspiration et de
monopole qui se constitue d'un google et
autres entreprises des dégâts fa alors
bon de nouveau sur le sur le dernier
point le dernier point c'est simplement
je crois que la liste de toutes ces
actions seulement évidemment quand on
les prendre dans c'est pas forcément
très nouveau vous avez raison ça n'est
qu'une raison de plus pour agir en
réalité le fait que le constat soit déjà
établi depuis un certain temps et il est
temps d'agir parce que les écarts se
creusent donc
donc il faut agir alors donc je crois
qu'il ya quand même une variété de
levier qui est assez vite assez
importante
ce qu'il faut évidemment c'est tout
chacun va déplorer le fait que nous
n'avons que dans gaza il n'y a pas un
seul européen dans l'est dans l'étape
lettre et que c'est bien sûr ça le
problème
simplement je crois que ça a été évoqué
dans votre d'autres auditions
malheureusement ça n'est pas une start
up qui aujourd'hui va facilement
déplacer les choses on n'est plus dans
un monde où les start-ups affrontera été
dit je le répète évidemment on a là des
gens avec une capacité à investir et à
embaucher les meilleurs talents qui voit
là ça n'est plus la bonne idée c'est
également la capacité a statistiquement
couvrir toutes les idées possibles qui
fait qu'on réussit une capacité à
acquérir celui qui réussit voilà donc
tout ça et apprendre extrêmement au
sérieux et notre propos est simplement
de dire que regardons les choses un peu
dans leur ensemble un peu plus largement
que ça ces gens n'existent que parce
qu'il y à une infrastructure en dessous
et l'infrastructure n'existe que parce
qu'il ya un secteur industriel s'appelle
la haute technologie qui existe en
dessous aussi et que ça ça reste encore
au plan mondial
et quand on fait la somme des deux on va
se retrouver sur donc 4000 milliards de
dollars ça reste une industrie qui est
très beaucoup plus importante que les
quatre gars femmes mises ensemble
évidemment au rythme où ils vont c'est
vrai que c'est assez c'est assez
préoccupant mais enfin voilà on ce qu'on
dit en tout cas c'est que les sous
jacents on peut on peut les consolider
il ya beaucoup il ya beaucoup dax
possible votre première question c'est
pas un hasard que on est coécrit cette
étude avec un allemand et un suédois
c'est vrai alors l'échelle notre cabinet
ça pourrait être un hasard mais en fait
ça ça ne l'est pas effectivement c ces
deux pays sont éléments extrêmement
concernés par ce sujet quand on prend la
liste tout simplement les huit qui sont
dans le top 100 vous allez trouver
quatre français ont été trouvés et puis
après les autres sont des allemands
et ça paie t systems atos il ya qui sont
franco allemand et puis il ya ericsson
donc évidemment il était micro et dont
on va dire français basé à genève
d'origine française évidemment c'est la
france et l'allemagne qui vont tirer ce
secteur donc c'est bien sûr ces deux
pays là qui doivent être je dirais en
leadership sûr sûr sûr le discours est
sûre et sur les actes voilà alors sur la
question de la fiscalité donc bien
entendu je dirais ça paraît assez assez
évident mais simplement je donc donc il
faut le faire
ne nous trompons pas il faudrait
davantage moi plutôt partisan de la
carotte plutôt que partisans du bâton
c'est bien plutôt que de taper sur
google
essayons de favoriser nos entreprises
essayons de faire émerger un concurrent
essayons de protéger l'industrie qui
fait la force de l'europe
je pense que ça le propos que j'aurais
là dessus par ailleurs nous sommes pas
des fiscalistes dont je veux pas non
plus apporté d'éclairage très
particulier c'est vrai que ça n'a pas
été mentionné si vous voulez de façon
aussi importante que dans les débats
classiques dont que l'on voit le sujet
c'est le financement le sujet c'est
l'éducation
le sujet ce sont les kloster et c'est la
coopération industrielle entre les
différents dans la chaîne de valeur
entre les donneurs d'ordre et les
fournisseurs etc
le fléchage des dépenses publiques
vraiment ça qui ressort
vous évoquez les par exemple c'est
d'investir dans un domaine comme celui
des moteurs de recherche pour le coup
est ce que c'est vraiment le sens de ce
qu'il faut faire ou est-ce qu'il faut
pas déjà anticipé vous avez évoqué
notamment les objets connectés les
objets intelligents
est ce que ces captures dans cette
direction qui vous faire porter l'effort
deuxième fois je suis question si on a
les moyens plus limités est ce que pour
le coup il faut pas plutôt jouer des
coudes après est-ce que c'est pas la
dynamique n'est pas de ce côté là dans
cette dynamique vous n'évoquez pas le
rôle que pourrait jouer alors vous
indiquer les moyens parfois limité
qu'ils y consacrent
mais pourquoi et comment les grands
groupes européens et français ne jouent
pas un rôle plus net je pense par
exemple dans les objets connectés à edf
ou vous avez évoqué le rôle que pourra
jouer france et comme on a un secteur
bancaire et assurantiel qui est parmi
les plus performants du monde pourquoi
est-ce que ce secteur n'investit pas lui
non plus ne fait pas le choix l'une en
plus de développer des initiatives dans
ces domaines est ce que c'est une
orientation qu'on peut imaginer
puis enfin troisièmement est ce que vous
estimez on regarde ce que vous avez vu
que l'organisation aujourd'hui
européenne est bien adapté pour répondre
aux défis que vous indiquez vous parler
de plan particulier pour soutenir ses
activités ce que vous sentez aujourd'hui
une capacité à l'échelon européen de
porter un tel plan ou est-ce qu'il faut
imaginer des formes d'organisation
différence qu'il faut imaginer pour le
coup une sorte dieu spécifique qui
serait dédié à la haute technologie
des initiatives en la matière parce
qu'on peut compter sur les institutions
existantes dans votre point de vue en
tant qu' en tant que praticien on
revient sur la question du moteur de
recherche
bien évidemment il faut préparer le coup
d'après bien évidemment les objets
connectés représente une opportunité
puisque évidemment ça va prendre ne
serait-ce qu'en masse et ça va surtout
toucher tous les verticaux donc il est
clair il faut bien entendu se mobiliser
là dessus après ces objets connectés ils
ne vont faire que générer de la data
supplémentaire donc qui
larmes de la guerre restera toujours la
capacité à trouver dans l'information
pléthorique ce qui est important et
donner du sens à ce titre je pense que
faire l'impasse malheureusement sur les
algorithmes de recherche et probablement
risqué puisque jeu c'est intrinsèque
même à la société de l'information
aujourd'hui donc il faut continuer
simplement je mets ça va en évidence
l'ampleur des moyens mais qui sont à
l'échelle de l'impact de ce set de ce
type de service tout simplement c'est
pas finalement by milliards de dollars
de recherche pour quelque chose qui
bouleverse à peu près la totalité des
secteurs c'est pas forcément un chiffre
déraisonnable donc simplement voilà
c'est prendre conscience de l'ampleur
peut-être de la marche mais probablement
pas faire l'impasse parce que je il y
aura toujours besoin d'un algorithme de
recherche est de plus en plus je pense
que les secteurs académiques français
allemand enfin de tout le tout lé pays
dispose disposer du curriculum et de la
capacité de recherche fondamentale qui
pourrait tout à fait bien sûr vous faire
bouger les lignes
faut juste s'assurer que nos chercheurs
ne partent pas immédiatement en
californie dès qu'ils ont une bonne idée
c'est c'est ça le csah point votre
deuxième question
ah oui sur la mobilisation des grosses
entreprises je pense que c'est
effectivement au coeur un petit peu de
ce que l'on dit c'est à dire que
l'audience se sont hauts c'est autour
d'eux qu'il faut construire les clusters
dans les secteurs énergétique dans les
secteurs dont on a parlé qui sont les
secteurs forts on me dirait ils ne le
font pas il faut sans doute les
convaincre que effectivement leurs
positions et potentiellement menacés il
faut être proactif vis-à-vis de en tout
cas il faut leur donner probablement le
mandat de définir leurs besoins et
d'orienter la filière technologique vers
ses besoins si on prend l'exemple de dfc
frappant par exemple vers le compteur
intelligent et il n'est pas du tout
conçu dans la perspective d'être
utilisés alors prié tous les projets de
protection de données on est bien
content d'accord mais elle n'est pas du
tout été conçu dans cette perspective
d'ouvrir odf avant ça les données qui va
récupérer sur une démarche plus large
qui pourrait être extrêmement
valorisante
non moi je tout à fait d'accord il
encaisse qui explique cette réticence
d'endosser culturel comme diraient les à
chaque fois que la famille se pose la
question est est ce que ces cultures
je ne sais pas si elles sont là c'est
culturel mais voilà bon enfin en tout
cas je veux pas qualifier exactement au
bout d'un moment ça devient culturel oui
c'est l'exploitation qu'on puisse donner
alors je pense que je pense que comme
vous le dites vous faites référence à
protection des données en fait c'est le
débat est un petit peu ga pas qu'il est
confus mais le débat est complexe le
débat et c'est quelque chose de nouveau
et bien sûr qu'il ya des forces de
rappel qui ne sont pas toujours
favorables à quelque chose de très
proactive d'un point de vue industriel
donc peut-être que ces acteurs là eux
mêmes se contraignent un petit peu dans
leurs perspectives parce qu'ils sont
alimentées aussi par toute sorte de
dimension
dans son pays s'ils ont souvent public
au départ donc
donc voilà mais enfin l'eee en tout cas
les gens de cette industrie là ils sont
plutôt les acteurs a finalement de la
digitalisation sont tous convaincus qu
effectivement ce sont les donneurs
d'ordre industriels des verticaux qui
doivent être à l'origine de la direction
que l'on souhaite donner aux
investissements à l'échelle européenne
et les utilities allemandes et
néerlandais sont très forte également
donc tout à fait est fait et bien mon
échelle en plein gré est-ce qu'il faut
travailler sur d'autres types
d'organisation et ce qu'il faut pour le
coup un dispositif spécifique une
organisation européenne spécifique
pendant serge ces sujets ce qu'on peut
le faire dans notre quête de lieux est
ce que vous sentez des des étapes quand
on a vu la rencontre récente remada
merkel et monsieur hollande on a eu le
sentiment qu'ils parlaient pas tout à
fait la même chose là merkel parler d'un
internet européen surprend d'ailleurs
nous dire ce qu'elles mettaient derrière
le président de la république française
lui évoquait plutôt justement une forme
de coopération sur les technologies dont
on ne savait pas très bien encore sous
quelle forme ça pouvait se faire dans
les sentiments qui sont restés un peu
sur chacun son quant-à-soi alors que
vous appelez plutôt immobilisée sur de
l'un et de l'autre
voilà donc voila vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit ce qui est important c'est que les
débats existent qu'il qu'il progresse il
est certain que c'est ce couple là qui
est alors je pourrai pas des personnes
des états qui sont évidemment qui
détiennent la clé aujourd'hui de 7
le fus du futur qu'on voudra se se
construire
payer ses skis c'est quelque chose à
travers les contacts que vous avez
justement sur l'échelle européenne dans
l'eau relate que vous sentez à l'échelle
regard dynamisme ans c'est sûr que le
débat a été déjà la place de ce secteur
parmi d'autres que l'union européenne
arbitres sur beaucoup de secteurs
industriels
j'ai même à mon collègue suédois qui me
parle de la politique agricole commune
si vous voulez donc ça ça fait partie le
mans delà de la peacher je crois que
c'est en train d'évoluer
ce qui est de nouveau plus 25% sur un
budget c'est quand même machine
significatif donc de nouveau la
direction est bonne
l'ampleur n'est pas probablement là et
bien entendu il va falloir faire des
choix difficiles parce qu'il faut
effectivement se placer à une échelle
européenne il faut être habile sur la
façon dont on formule je passe ici la
gouvernance ou si c'est qu'ils tirent
quoi c'est une vision un peu simpliste
des choses mais à un moment donné c'est
une c'est une solution en tout cas vu
des états unis et vu que l'asie
évidemment ça serait quelque chose qui
serait pris extrêmement sérieux
les échos quelles sont les conséquences
de la sicile la situation vous décrivez
aujourd'hui qui est je rappe si on
restait sur la première partie de votre
intervention on arriverait quand même à
une situation un peu un peu un peu
dramatique quelles sont ces imaginons
que rien ne bouge quelles sont les
conséquences de votre point de vue du
point de vue de notre dynamique
industrie et technologie que l'évolution
de l'emploi notre capacité à conserver
des emplois qualifiés ce que vous avez
regardé cette place parce qu'on est
capable on ferra scénario doit on n'a
pas fait un scénario noir déjà il ya eu
une interprétation qui a été faite de
l'étude comme quoi elle était pessimiste
je crois qu'elle est pauvre qu'elle est
juste factuelle ou contraire à la montre
qu'il ya des solutions donc elle ouvre
des pistes alors ça se passait rien à
votre avis qu'est-ce comment va évoluer
l'économie mondiale sur ces domaines et
quelle place l'europe y tiendrait c'est
pour le coup la réaction rester aussi
faible et modeste que celle que vous
décrivez une écoute et c'est très simple
le secteur de nouveau un les sociétés de
services informatiques et une dimension
extrêmement locales dans ce type de
travail donc elles resteront
probablement à leur place
encore qu effectivement les tout ce qui
est autour du cloud e rang quelque part
la proximité peut être un petit peu
moins pertinent enfin on reste quand
même au contact des entreprises ont que
ça reste ça reste un élément locale mais
le segment des de la communication des
équipements donc ericsson alcatel nokia
siemens est évidemment est un est un
secteur qui s'il n'est pas soutenue
évidemment se fera déplacer
voilà avec donc après l'impossibilité
cette fois pour les infrasons blanc
devront au coeur de l'infrastructure des
opérateurs eux-mêmes de maîtriser la
technologie qu'ils ont à leur réseau je
pense que c'est quand même pour le coup
une vision assez assez noir je sais pas
après jusqu'où ça peut aller en terme
d'impact ça dont on n'a pas fait ce
scénario là c'est plutôt ce sans se
focaliser sur l'idée que c'est cette
photographie il ya trois ans il y avait
je crois qu'il y avait douze acteurs
trois ans plus tard il y en a plus que 9
- 1 avec nokia staff et 2,8 après vous
pouvez comme moi tiré le trait ça soit
une vision un peu simple de notre métier
de faire ça mais vraiment ça peut donner
une direction
oui je voulais juste revenir sur un
point de détail et vous demander votre
point de vue sur le crédit impôt
recherche comme monter son efficacité ou
non selon vous nouveau l'étude et
peut-être au plan européen mais
clairement ça fait partie des mesures
extrêmement
valable profitable qu'il faut encourager
100 ans sans état d'âme enfin je pense
qu'il ya même pas de question sur ce
sujet là et l'arbitrage qui consiste à
dire oui il faut prévu ce type vgg
uniquement les grosses entreprises par
rapport aux petites vont bien sûr il
faut il faut travailler avec les
startups il faut travailler que les pme
qui sont fragiles mais on le voit ici
dans ce secteur là la dynamique elle est
mondiale et ce qu'il faut c'est que des
champions émergent et peut-être s'il ya
des priorités à donner
oui j'avais une question aux compléments
de cela parce que vous parlez de la
politique européenne effectivement
horizon 20 20 + 25 % fait la demande est
très loin des 100 millions qui a été
réclamée quand même c'est à dire qu'on
reste quand même d'aider dans des
perspectives très restreinte et je vous
parle pas de l'intérieur du contenu la
fragilité l'intégration de de certains
grands projets dans le cadre où on est
loin quand même du compte mais surtout
sur crédit impôt recherche on ait eu
l'occasion il n'y a pas très longtemps
de d'auditionner monsieur joaquín
almunia alors c'est vrai le crédit
d'impôt recherche
on le favorise beaucoup mais on oublie
complètement les autres formes de crédit
d'impôt qui sont des crédits d'impôt
sectorielles ou au contraire la l'union
européenne joue des règles qui se
veulent protectrice de la concurrence
qui font que c'est pas tout de
développer de la recherche est d'avoir
des chercheurs européens de très grande
qualité
si ces entreprises ne sont pas soutenus
quand on voit la manière dont l'amérique
du nord les états unis le canada font
leur relocalisation industrielle ou des
places des entreprises européennes
je crois que là on a loupé en un maillon
manquant et qu' est-ce qu'on n'est pas
dans une vision un peu théorie c'est à
dire si la recherche est forte et
dynamique qu'on l'aide toute la chaîne
va suivre alors que la chaîne est faible
je partage complètement votre point de
vue vient tout le monde feront le
partage déjà qu'il faut soutenir la
recherche et par contre il ne faut pas
se satisfaire avant d'être bon aux
recherches et d'avoir des médailles et
aider des sur l'innovation du modèle
américain comme vous le savez tous ce
n'est pas fondé sur la recherche il est
fondé sur le développement et
l'industrialisation des profs des
procédés et donc c'est bien lent nous ce
qu'on a noté de positif au moins au plan
qualitatif avec le plan 20 20 c'est
précisément qu'il est ce volet
industriel
bon il ya maintenant il ya trop il ya 3
il ya trois boîtes avec deux il y avait
uniquement la recherche et les secteurs
là il ya vraiment ce volet industriel et
je crois que les allemands seront tout à
fait réceptif 7 à cette idée qu'il faut
industrialiser lampe très bien écouter
et malheureusement le leurre dont nous
disposions est maintenant écoulé merci
beaucoup de d'avoir tiré ce devant nous
se signale la larme déjà présent dans
votre étude
en espérant que soyez entendu ne soyons
entendus à travers la sans doute
beaucoup de propositions vous évoquez 2
on en a discuté probablement à reprendre
merci beaucoup monsieur la presse voilà
pour cette audition de hervé collignon
vice-président de cabinet at kearney
spécialiste des télécommunications des
nouvelles technologies et des médias
vous pouvez bien sûr toujours voir et
revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site sur publicsenat.fr
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire et bien à 19h pour 24
heures sénat présenté par delphine
girard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires